sénateurs communistes des hauts-de-seine
pierrot tu y as pour réagir à
l'actualité
oui pierre buyoya ce bon jour là c'était
dangereux colbert devant l'assemblée
nationale a été dégradée avec cette
inscription 1 négrophobie d'état quelle
est votre réaction
moi je suis historien donc je vais faire
je vais vous faire une observation
d'historiens alors là vous êtes dans la
salle des conférences au sénat là vous
avez un certain nombre de fresques
historiques là par exemple il ya ya
clovis bon clovis il faut l'effacer
c'est quelqu'un qui a cassé le vase de
soissons ça se fait pas c'est pas bien
bon genre j'en plaisante un peu mais je
je pense que l'histoire ce n'est pas un
tribunal
l'histoire c'est ce qui permet de
comprendre de mettre en parallèle des
processus de les identifier
si on commence aujourd'hui à juger tous
les personnages de notre histoire
d'abord on n'y arrivera pas et je pense
que c'est pas que ces vins c'est pas
c'est pas intéressant donc ce que je ce
que je préférerais mois plutôt que de de
s'en prendre comme ça à des à des
statuts c'est que on lance un vrai
travail de réflexion sur qu'est ce qu'a
été la traite la traite des noirs
pendant une bonne partie de notre
histoire
comment napoléon 1er dont vous avez le
le trône ici à réinstaurer les
esclavages dans les antilles alors que
l' esclavage avait été avait été
supprimée donc là il ya des vraies
questions d'histoire et je pense qu'il
faudrait j'aurais travaillé là dessus ça
serait plus intéressant que de que de
s'en prendre aux statuts si je comprends
bien vous condamner cet acte et vous
comprenez en même temps que la mémoire
d'un colbert ministre de louis xiv donc
initiateur du code noir de qui légifère
sur l'esclavagé dans les colonies puisse
susciter des réactions chez certains de
nos compatriotes mais c'est toute
l'histoire qui doit susciter des
réactions
je pense qu'on doit s'interroger en
permanence sur notre histoire
sur quelle est notre histoire de quoi
elle se elle se constitue notre histoire
coloniale doit être repensée absolument
repenser je pense que notre âme en
notamment notre histoire coloniale en
afrique du nord et en algérie doit être
un sujet d'intérêt d'études et
aujourd'hui il faut consacrer beaucoup
de moyens pour pour comprendre ce que la
france a fait la barre ça c'est je pense
que ça c'est essentiel
voilà c'est à dire question comment on
des patios justement là ce débat on va
passer par un traitement historique des
données historiques dont distancié où on
essaye de mettre en parallèle de
constituer l'effet de les mettre en
parallèle et de l'est et de les
comprendre
si on aborde notre passé historique avec
un souci de juger avec nos conceptions
actuelles on n'y arrivera pas et c'est
pas très intéressant vous êtes historien
vous savez qu une différence entre
histoire et mémoire la statue d'un
colbert c'est aussi un signe mémorielle
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ces cas là les
mais l'âme la mémoire moi je
l'entretiens autrement mais différemment
par exemple je suis tous les ans aux
moines moniales du mont valérien pour
célébrer la mémoire des résistants qui
ont été fusillés et je porte une un
regard particulier sur ce qu'ils ont
fait et ce pour quoi ils ont été
fouillés fusillés et j'essaye de
défendre les idées pour lesquelles ils
ont été fusillés pour moi là il ya un
acte de mémoire qui est fort et qui est
intéressant parce qu'il est constructif
et positif
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur
d'avoir répondu à mes questions c'est à
vous tam en plateau oui merci beaucoup s